I think now is a terrific or important
time to understand the mechanics of debt
debt creation and how does it work and
how does it bring about crises uh
the debt limit you think about the debt
limit is a good thing that we're passing
the debt limit or not you know
and so
um
in 2008 I did a study to get us through
the 2008 financial crisis and we did
very well in that and that study 10
years later uh treasury secretary
Paulson uh Tim Geithner treasury
secretary Tim Geithner and Ben Bernanke
asked me to put that out as a book and
that book there's a physical book and
you can get it free as a PDF file
goes through the mechanics of debt so it
looks at all the last 100 years big debt
crises and you could understand the
mechanics of that and I'd really like
you to understand the mechanics rather
than just deal with the outcome so
you're making your own decisions and you
can learn from that so it's a good time
to take a look at either you know the
physical book or to take a look at the
free PDF